hace un año todos los focos estaban
sobrehumana y el primer confinamiento
total frente al coronavirus en el mundo
poco a poco la ciudad va retornando a la
normalidad y algunos celebran pero no de
la mejor manera
vacunarse es reducir el riesgo de ser
infectado pero creo que el gobierno ha
señalado claramente que no significa que
se puedan ignorar las precauciones de
seguridad como el uso de mascarillas y
otras medidas sino que hay que tomarlas
bien si en la ciudad de más de 11
millones de habitantes la situación se
aproxima a una vuelta a la normalidad el
resto del país está a la expectativa en
las provincias de hebei e incluso en
algunos distritos de beijing los
rebrotes siguen aumentando con la
presencia de casos de la variante
británica las autoridades confirmaron
nuevamente a pocas semanas de las
celebraciones del año nuevo lunar las
campañas de vacunación se han
intensificado y piden a la ciudadanía
abstenerse de viajar
jaime o pensión creo que los habitantes
de wuhan han pasado por mucho y son
realmente increíbles sacrificaron sus
libertades durante el cierre de wuhan
[Música]
contribuyeron mucho a la lucha de china
contra la pandemia
por otro lado el vecino japón acelera
los preparativos para la vacunación con
la esperanza de comenzar la a finales de
febrero pero la incertidumbre crece a
medida que el país se enfrenta a un
público reacio a las vacunas
comunicaciones tarjeta touring y nuestro
objetivo de llevar a cabo la inoculación
con precisión siguiendo las órdenes del
gobierno central o incitando a luján y
este donde por lo tanto deseamos que el
gobierno central nos notifique pronto
y tú multi más el país nipón también
insiste en su idea de celebrar los
juegos olímpicos y pese a los rumores de
cancelación por la gravedad de la
pandemia el gobierno lo negó